YURI GRINSHTEYN: We've seen
how to create service level
objectives for services
running on GKE.
But what if your
services aren't?
Today, I'm going to show you
how to create custom services
and define SLOs to
measure their reliability.
This is The Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As we covered in
our earlier episode,
services running on
GKE are automatically
discovered by SLO
monitoring, if you were
using the Istio service mesh.
If you're not, you can
easily select GKE entities
and create services
against them.
If your services
aren't on GKE, you
need to define them
as custom services.
As you can see,
you're not limited
to just the out-of-the box
service types and service
monitoring.
You can create custom services.
You have two options.
You can use the API directly, or
you can use an automation tool
like Terraform.
Once the service is
created, you can then
use the UI to create
SLOs against it.
Let's take a look at
the API method first.
To invoke the API, make a
POST request of the services
endpoint within your project,
specifying the service
ID as a parameter.
The body of the request
should contain the name
you'd like to see in the UI.
And there you are.
Now that the service
has been created,
you can use the UI to
create an SLO against it.
Note that you have to
specify "other" as the metric
for your SLI.
This is a custom
service, and there
is no automatic measure of
performance or availability
for it.
As such, you need to have
a good SLI for the service.
For a start, you might be
able to use a metric admitted
by the Google Cloud load
balancer, such as request
count.
Otherwise, you
want to instrument
your service to admit SLIs.
For an example, take a
look at our earlier episode
by using OpenTelemetry
to do just that.
As you can see, creating
a custom service
using an API call is
pretty straightforward.
From there, you could
use the API or the UI
to define your SLO.
But what if you want to
automate this process?
This is where
Terraform comes in.
You may remember that we covered
using Terraform to create
monitoring configurations
like uptime checks,
dashboards, and the
learning policies
in the previous episode.
If not, no worries.
We'll link to that
episode below.
To quickly bring
you up to speed,
Terraform is an open
source tool that
allows us to define
infrastructure and monitoring
configurations as code.
That includes defining
services and SLOs.
Here's how you can define a
service and an SLO against it
in Terraform.
Let's walk through the code
together so that it's clear.
First, define the basics.
Specify Google Cloud
as the provider,
and define your service.
For the service, you just
need to provide a service
ID that's unique to your
project and a display name.
Next, define the SLO.
Specify an ID for it
and a display name.
Next, specify whether you
want to use a request-based
or a windows-based SLI.
Then, specify the metric
you want to use as your SLI.
And finally, determine how you'd
like the SLI to be evaluated.
Note that I'm just using a
single metric in this example.
For a request-based SLO, you
might have separate metrics
that you want to
use to represent
total requests and good requests
or perhaps the same metrics
with different filters applied.
Both of those are
absolutely supported
by SLO monitoring to allow
you to calculate a ratio.
The final step is to define
your target or goal, expressed
as a fraction that
should be less than 1,
and your compliance period as
either a rolling or a calendar
window.
Once your definition is done,
run the "terraform plan"
command to validate
your configuration
and make sure that the two
resources will be created--
your service and your SLO.
Finally, run "terraform
apply" to actually create
the resources.
Confirm that you want to
do this at the prompt,
and verify that the two
resources you wanted got
created.
Return to the
console, and verify
that your service was
created and that it
has an SLO defined against it.
In the services detail
screen, make sure
that your service is currently
compliant with your SLO,
if that's what you expect.
Thanks for joining me today.
We learned how to define
custom services using the API
and Terraform and how
to automate setting up
SLOs against our services.
Now you are ready to start
defining your own services
and setting SLOs against them.
Thanks for watching, and
come back soon for more.
This is The Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]